(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre a matrícula
do imóvel e a importância de sua análise
para participar de um leilão.
A matrícula do imóvel é o documento que
individualiza aquele imóvel, que vai apresentar todas as
características daquele imóvel.
Então, a matrícula, em primeiro lugar, ela traz
a definição daquele imóvel, qual é a área
privativa daquele imóvel, se for um imóvel que
pertence a um condomínio, seja uma casa ou
um apartamento, a matrícula vai apresentar a área
comum do imóvel.
O que é a área comum do imóvel?
A área comum é aquela área que qualquer
imóvel que está dentro de um condomínio tem
direito sobre o terreno.
Isso também pode ser chamado de fração ideal.
Então, um apartamento, ele tem direito, além da
área privativa, a uma área daquele terreno.
E aí vai constar a área privativa do
imóvel, do apartamento, e a área comum daquele
terreno que pertence àquele apartamento.
E depois a área total, que é a
soma da área privativa com a área comum.
A matrícula lá vai trazer a informação de
todos os proprietários que já passaram por aquele
bem.
Quando ocorreu um contrato de compra e venda,
quem vendeu para quem, se aquele imóvel já
foi hipotecado, se aquele imóvel foi dado em
garantia para alguma dívida, todas essas informações vão
constar na matrícula.
Então, a matrícula é de fundamental análise para
a gente participar ou não de um loilão.
Porque na matrícula você vai saber tudo o
que já aconteceu com aquele imóvel, quem já
foi o proprietário, quem é o atual proprietário.
A qualificação desse proprietário, os dados do proprietário
constam na matrícula do imóvel.
Consta identidade, CPF, o endereço de quando ele
comprou aquele imóvel, o valor que ele pagou
por aquele imóvel, se ele comprou aquele imóvel
de maneira financiada ou não, se ele hipotecou
aquele imóvel, se ele fez um contrato de
aliança com aquele imóvel, isso tudo tem que
constar na matrícula.
A matrícula é um documento público.
Qualquer pessoa pode requerer a matrícula.
Basta que você compareça a um cartório de
registro de imóveis, onde aquele imóvel está matriculado,
ou que você peça online.
Você vai ter direito a olhar aquela matrícula.
Não é um documento reescrito, é um documento
público para qualquer interessado.
Então, qualquer pessoa interessada pode ter acesso a
esse documento e verificar todo o histórico do
imóvel.
A matrícula está registrada em um cartório de
imóveis.
Cidades maiores possuem vários cartórios de imóveis, divididos
por zonas.
Um bairro fica responsável por uma zona tal,
outro cartório vai ficar responsável por outra zona,
e assim ocorre uma divisão da cidade.
Cidades menores tendem a ter um único cartório
de registro de imóveis.
Aquele único cartório vai concentrar todas as matrículas
dos imóveis daquela cidade.
Então, você como interessado em um leilão, você
tem que verificar a matrícula, justamente porque a
matrícula vai trazer todo o histórico do imóvel.
Vai apresentar se existe alguma dívida que está
recaindo sobre aquele imóvel, se aquele imóvel está
garantindo algum contrato.
Como a gente já falou anteriormente, um contrato
de alienação fiduciária, ele pode ter como garantia
um bem imóvel.
Para que esse contrato tenha validade contra todos,
ele tem que necessariamente estar registrado na matrícula
do imóvel, porque a matrícula do imóvel é
um documento público.
E como um documento público, a partir do
momento que um contrato de garantia está registrado
na matrícula, todos têm conhecimento daquilo.
Basta que você requeira essa matrícula no cartório
de imóveis.
Então, por exemplo, se o contrato de alienação
fiduciária não estiver registrado na matrícula, ele vai
ter validade unicamente entre as partes que celebraram
aquele contrato.
De um lado o credor fiduciário, de outro
o devedor fiduciante.
Ele não vai ter validade contra mais ninguém
da sociedade, justamente porque ele não estava registrado
na matrícula.
O registro é um requisito necessário para que
ele possa valer contra todos.
Então, retomando, a matrícula vai trazer todos os
dados de todos os proprietários, os dados de
dívidas que já existiram naquele imóvel, os dados
de dívidas que estão recaindo naquele imóvel naquele
exato momento que você requerer a matrícula.
Então, a matrícula junto com o edital do
leilão são os documentos mais importantes para você
analisar.
A matrícula, ela costuma ainda trazer o número
de inscrição imobiliária no qual aquele imóvel está
registrado na prefeitura do município em que ele
está localizado.
Então, por exemplo, a matrícula de um imóvel
aqui da cidade de São Paulo, ela costuma
apresentar o número de inscrição municipal desse imóvel
na prefeitura.
E esse número é muito importante para quem
quer participar de um leilão também.
Isso porque com esse número você vai conseguir
visualizar débitos de IPTU que existam sobre aquele
imóvel, outros débitos tributários que recaiam sobre aquele
imóvel.
Pode ser ainda que esse número de inscrição
municipal, ele tenha mudado durante a existência do
imóvel.
Se ele tiver mudado, essa informação também consta
da matrícula.
Primeiro vai ter um número e depois no
corpo da matrícula vai apresentar o número informando
que esse número foi modificado pela prefeitura da
cidade tal, que é a cidade onde o
imóvel está localizado e passa a constar com
tal número.
Existem alguns casos que a matrícula, ela não
vai apresentar esse número de inscrição municipal.
E aí você não vai conseguir verificar os
débitos desse imóvel pela internet.
Isso porque quase todos os municípios do Brasil,
eles informatizaram esse sistema para consulta de dívidas
de IPTU e outros tributos que possam recair
sobre aquele imóvel.
Basta que você faça uma busca na internet,
possuindo essa inscrição imobiliária, que você consiga averiguar
quais os débitos que recaem ou não naquele
imóvel.
Se a matrícula não apresentar essa inscrição imobiliária,
você não vai conseguir fazer essa busca pela
internet.
Você vai ter que comparecer pessoalmente à prefeitura
daquela cidade ou pedir para alguém compareça em
seu nome para buscar o número de inscrição
imobiliária daquele imóvel e assim realizar a consulta.
Vou mostrar aqui um exemplo prático de como
fazer essa consulta de um imóvel que eu
abri aleatoriamente.
Eu escolhi o leiloeiro Zuckerman, que talvez seja
o leiloeiro mais conhecido do país.
Ele acaba realizando leilão no Brasil inteiro, em
casos de leilões extrajudiciais, mas para casos de
leilão judicial, ele só realiza leilão determinado pelo
Tribunal de Justiça de São Paulo.
Então vamos lá, eu abri aqui o site
do Zuckerman, escolhi de forma aleatória o imóvel
no Guarajá.
A gente não vai analisar esse imóvel agora.
É um leilão judicial, como está aqui o
símbolo do Tribunal de Justiça de São Paulo,
com toda a informação de que ele é
um leilão judicial.
A primeira praça já ocorreu em 11 de
maio de 2020.
O valor de avaliação dele foi superior a
quase 4 milhões e meio.
E a segunda praça vai ocorrer em 1º
de junho de 2020, por um desconto de
pouco mais de 30%, equivalendo ao lance mínimo
a pouco mais de 3 milhões.
Então, o Zuckerman já apresenta os detalhes do
imóvel, o Guarajá, a rua do imóvel, o
número, o lote.
Isso aqui é uma casa de um condomínio.
Tem imagens da casa aqui, pra gente dar
uma verificada.
Tem outras informações, como a área construída, dormitórios,
suítes.
E aqui o Zuckerman, ele bota os documentos
do lote, lado de avaliação e matrícula do
imóvel.
Então o que a gente quer analisar agora
é a matrícula do imóvel, que eu quero
mostrar pra vocês como funciona.
Cliquei na matrícula, ele vai me trazer informações.
Esse imóvel está registrado sobre o número 93
.622 no Cartório de Registro de Imóveis de
Guarujá.
O Guarujá, aparentemente, não tem mais de um
cartório, porque se tivesse mais de um cartório
na divisão, aqui ficaria o segundo cartório, o
terceiro cartório, mas veja que só tem Cartório
de Registro de Imóveis de Guarujá.
A primeira coisa da matrícula é sempre apresentar
os dados daquele bem.
Então a gente pode ver aqui, um terreno
constituído pelo lote 5 e pelo lote 6
da quadratal, loteamento tal, município de Guarujá, com
frente para a rua tal, e dar todas
as informações.
E aqui depois ele apresenta, cadastro pela Prefeitura
Municipal de Guarujá sobre o número.
Então esse número aqui é o número que
a gente vai precisar usar pra localizar os
débitos de IPTU que esse imóvel possui.
Então a gente vai usar como Google, consulta,
IPTU Guarujá São Paulo.
Primeiro link, serviços online, Prefeitura Municipal de Guarujá.
Clicamos, ele vai aparecer em primeiro lugar, consulta
débitos.
Você vai abrir a outra aba, e ele
vai pedir pra você colocar a identificação desse
imóvel pelo número de IPTU dele.
Então o número de IPTU é esse aqui,
30801, e até o final dele.
O Zuckerman, ele já botou esse número aqui,
que fica mais fácil pra copiar, então por
isso que eu vou usar o número que
o próprio site apresentou aqui.
Vou copiar e vou jogar nesse campo de
identificação e pedir pra buscar.
Pronto, o site já me apresenta, o proprietário,
o valor total de IPTU devido pra esse
imóvel, que tá um pouco mais de 10
mil reais.
Então essa é a forma da gente localizar
os débitos de IPTU que existem sobre o
imóvel.
Como eu falei antes, as prefeituras quase todas
informatizaram esse serviço, né, pra ficar mais fácil,
pra que a pessoa não tenha que comparecer
pessoalmente à prefeitura e pra também desafogar um
pouco a prefeitura, que não vai ter que
ter servidores ali fisicamente pra prestar uma informação
que pode ser facilmente conseguida por meio da
internet.
Você sempre deve fazer essa busca sobre os
débitos de IPTU que recaiam sobre o imóvel.
Especificamente sobre qual a consequência de ter débito
de IPTU ou outros débitos, a gente vai
estudar no módulo 2, em leilão extrajudicial, e
no módulo 3, porque as modalidades de leilão,
elas apresentam diferença sobre a responsabilidade de débitos
que recaiam sobre o imóvel.
Então por isso que a gente vai estudar
de forma individualizada no módulo 2 e no
módulo 3.
Isso aqui é só a forma pra vocês
entenderem como buscar débitos de IPTU, já que
a informação sobre a inscrição municipal do imóvel,
geralmente consta na matrícula do imóvel.
Então vamos continuar analisando a matrícula.
Primeiro apareceu proprietário, Luiz e Vera.
Aí a verbação número 1, o imóvel objeto
da presente matrícula possui atual descrição em virtude
de desmembramento.
A verbação número 2, por requerimento do Luiz,
que é um dos proprietários, como a gente
acabou de ver, ele pediu pra constar que
ficou construída a residência número 576 naquele terreno.
Depois tem aqui o registro número 3, uma
compra e venda.
Então o Luiz vendeu pra alguém, o Luiz
e a Vera venderam pra Alcides Carvalho.
E depois vai continuar todo o histórico daquele
imóvel.
Você pode ver que no registro número 4
já consta a informação de que Alcides vendeu
o imóvel para Maria e aí consta o
valor que ela vendeu.
Ela vendeu por 1 milhão em 27 de
outubro de 2016.
E depois vai continuar seguindo isso.
Ó a informação importante aqui.
A Maria, quando ela comprou, ela fez uma
alienação fiduciária.
Acabei de falar que é alienação fiduciária pra
ela ter eficácia contra todos.
Ela tem que estar registrada na matrícula do
imóvel.
Então veja que aqui ela está registrada.
Então essa alienação fiduciária, ela é de conhecimento
geral, porque a matrícula é um documento público.
Basta que você requeira no cartório que ela
está registrada.
Então está aqui a informação da alienação fiduciária.
Existem formas de você requerer a matrícula do
imóvel, tanto pessoalmente, comparecendo ao cartório em que
aquele imóvel está registrado, ou comparecendo em cidades
maiores, na central de registradores.
Em cidades maiores, como eu falei anteriormente, existem
vários cartórios de imóveis.
Então existe uma central para que você possa
fazer uma consulta unificada.
Você vai preencher o endereço do imóvel que
você está interessado em requerer a matrícula, pagar
a taxa, que a matrícula tem uma taxazinha,
e vai conseguir acesso a essa matrícula.
Mas existem formas de conseguir essa matrícula online.
E o nosso objetivo aqui é tentar fazer
o máximo possível à distância.
Isso porque você pode estar fora do Brasil
arrematando um imóvel, ou você pode estar no
sul do país arrematando um imóvel, ou em
São Paulo, no Rio de Janeiro, no Nordeste.
Isso é uma vantagem que o leilão online
te proporciona.
Você irá arrematar à distância.
Então vou ensinar aqui como fazer essa análise
toda à distância.
Existem três sites em que é possível você
requerer essa matrícula de forma online.
O primeiro site é esse aqui, cartóriosnobrasil.com
.br. Você vai entrar no site, e aqui
tem o link de principais serviços.
Você vai solicitar a certidão de um imóvel.
Você vai preencher os dados que o site
pedir e vai requerer essa matrícula.
Essa matrícula geralmente é enviada por correio para
você.
Então não deixe para fazer muito em cima
da hora, porque vai ter aquele prazo de
busca da matrícula inicialmente, e depois o prazo
do envio da matrícula.
Existe um outro cartório que faz esse mesmo
serviço, que é o cartório24horas.com.br, esse
site que está aqui.
É a mesma coisa, você vai solicitar a
sua matrícula de forma online, e ela vai
chegar até você.
Para alguns estados está disponível uma opção que
é muito mais vantajosa, que é nesse site
registradores.org.br. Veja, no registradores.org tem
um campo aqui à direita de matrícula online.
Você vai fazer o seu login, que é
bem simples, vai preencher, vai botar um e
-mail, vai botar uma senha, prosseguir, ele já
dá a possibilidade de você pedir um registro,
uma matrícula, ele tem um custo muito mais
barato, e essa matrícula já aparece na hora
para você.
Então você não tem que esperar a busca
no cartório, e nem o serviço dos correios.
Você vai automaticamente, ao preencher e pagar essa
matrícula, você vai ter acesso a ela na
hora.
Como fazer?
Você vem aqui em um novo pedido, e
ele vai te apresentar os estados que estão
disponíveis.
Como eu falei anteriormente, esse serviço do registradores
.org, diferente dos cartórios online, que você pode
pedir matrícula do Brasil inteiro, ele não está
disponível para o Brasil inteiro.
Ele só está disponível para Paraná, São Paulo,
Rio de Janeiro, Espírito Santo, Pernambuco, Pará e
Rondônia.
Então, para esses estados, você consegue ter acesso
à matrícula na hora.
Você não vai ter que esperar o serviço
dos cartórios, como nos outros dois exemplos que
eu mostrei anteriormente.
Serviços cartórios e serviços correios.
Aqui no registradores.org, nesses estados que estão
disponíveis, você tem acesso à matrícula na hora.
Então vamos supor, eu quero uma matrícula de
São Paulo, vou abrir aqui, vou concordar com
os termos e condições dele, prosseguir, preencher a
cidade do meu interesse, São Paulo capital, escolher
o cartório, veja, São Paulo capital tem 18
cartórios.
Como é uma cidade grande, acontece aquilo que
eu falei anteriormente.
A cidade fica dividida em zonas.
Você vai escolher um cartório específico, décimo cartório,
por exemplo, e botar o número da matrícula.
O número da matrícula, recapitulando, é esse que
consta logo em cima, aqui na matrícula.
Nesse caso aqui do imóvel do Guarujá, é
o 93.622. Então basta preencher aqui, clicar,
prosseguir, e a matrícula já aparece na hora
para mim.
Eu já fiz vários pedidos de matrícula, e
quando eu abro, aparece todo o histórico daqueles
pedidos que eu já fiz e o valor
que eu paguei.
Veja, todos eles ficaram abaixo de 20 reais
para eu ter uma matrícula na hora e
poder visualizar um documento que vai me dar
segurança para arrematar.
A matrícula, geralmente, é disponibilizada pelo próprio leiloeiro.
Então o leiloeiro, que eu mostrei no site
do Zuckerman, ele vai apresentar um campuzinho onde
vão ter os documentos do lote.
A matrícula, geralmente, é um documento que está
sempre presente em todos os sites do leiloeiro.
Você deve fazer esse procedimento de busca caso
o leiloeiro não apresente a matrícula ou caso
a matrícula apresentada pelo leiloeiro seja um pouco
antiga.
Vamos supor, um imóvel vai a leilão em
junho de 2020 e a matrícula que o
leiloeiro está apresentando é de janeiro de 2019.
Então tem mais de um ano daquela matrícula.
Pode ser que dentro daquele um ano, muita
coisa tenha acontecido com aquele imóvel.
Pode ser que aquele imóvel tenha sido dado
em garantia para alguma dívida.
Pode ser que tenha ocorrido uma mudança de
propriedade naquele imóvel.
Então se o leiloeiro não te apresentar essa
matrícula recente, eu aconselho sempre que você peça
uma matrícula, seja pelo serviço desses cartórios online,
no cartório 24 horas, ou no cartório no
Brasil, que são os dois sites que eu
mostrei anteriormente.
Nesse, saiba que você, ao requerer, vai esperar
um tempo para receber aquela matrícula em sua
mão.
Porque vai ter o tempo do busca no
cartório e depois o tempo dos correios para
entregar.
Se o imóvel de seu interesse estiver em
algum estado desses que eu mostrei que estão
vinculados ao site registradores.org, que a matrícula
aparece online na hora que você faz o
pedido, então você não vai precisar esperar esse
tempo do cartório e dos correios.
O processo vai ser muito facilitado, você vai
botar o número da matrícula e vai visualizar
aquela matrícula no mesmo momento que você pediu
a certidão.
Agora, a primeira coisa antes de você requerer
uma nova matrícula, caso um leiloeiro não tenha
apresentado aquela matrícula, é entrar em contato com
o leiloeiro.
Entre em contato com o leiloeiro e pergunte
se ele tem a matrícula daquele imóvel.
Porque geralmente leiloeiros têm.
Pode ser que por um equívoco o leiloeiro
não tenha carregado aquele documento junto com o
lote do imóvel.
Então não deixe nunca de analisar a matrícula
de um imóvel de um leilão que você
queira participar.
A matrícula em conjunto com o edital do
leilão são os documentos mais importantes para verificação
se deve ou não participar de um leilão
específico.
A matrícula, como eu falei, ela vai trazer
todos os dados do imóvel.
Então pode constar numa matrícula dados como uso
fruto, hipoteca, fração ideal ou outros termos.
Não precisa se preocupar, todos esses termos vão
ser estudados aqui no curso de uma maneira
mais didática possível.
Os termos jurídicos que possam aparecer nessa matrícula
eu vou tentar explicar da maneira mais simplificada
também.
Esse estudo vai acontecer no módulo 3.
Então pode ficar tranquilo que no módulo 3
você vai ter conhecimento de todos os termos
que podem aparecer na matrícula.
O objetivo dessa aula aqui era explicar o
que é a matrícula do imóvel e como
você pode conseguir essa matrícula de forma online.